[Music]
and lead by example news submitted by
passing cities yeah I like those Assam
tea lasted 12 minutes me yes damn high
school Thank You Bert high school
principal accused of plagiarizing and
ashton kutcher speech at graduation has
been suspended and it was like the
Nickelodeon one Kids Choice Awards
acceptance yes it was if we try to reach
to the kids who discovered it though
someone's like wait a minute sure
plagiarizing ashton kutcher speech it
should be it should be allowed it was
from 2013 Nickelodeon Teen Choice Awards
and so this Prince this principal from
West Virginia you pretty much the
identical speech is just that he
switched like little things here and
there
bands and the does a moment people do
when they play dress yeah so for example
are actually I don't even have to tell
you the example I can just show you it's
probably way easy to place your eyes now
than before I used to have to take the
water
no people can google that [ __ ] ah is it
again you just write one sentence and
they all pop up before if your teacher
was old enough he's gotta pay some [ __ ]
online and they met and never no I
didn't copy a page though I just [ __ ]
open the books and wrote when I was in
the book alright so this is a comparison
the side-by-side comparison of the two
speeches the first thing is about
opportunity the second thing is about
being intriguing and the third thing is
about living life so it's really three
things the first thing is about
opportunity the second thing is about
being sexy so you change the word sexy
thank you
and the third thing is about living life
so first the opportunity I believe that
opportunity looks a lot like hard work
so first opportunity I believe that
opportunity looks a lot like hard for my
god exactly job that was that I never
had a job in my life that I was better
than that I was too good for I was
always reluctant to just have a job and
I've never had a job in my life that I
was better than I was always just lucky
to have a job you didn't try Oh what
sucks is this is his free style and then
that guy had to copy and right and still
memorize and look they thought someone
else's fries transcribed freestyle no he
was just reading off of it yeah he was
just pretty that [ __ ] you did all this
work when it was just a stream of
consciousness dude that is so
embarrassing yeah like to get caught
plagiarizing Ashton Kutcher man like she
could she was [ __ ] hot you don't
think he's smart
no no it's not about that it's what he's
known for Celso no no I don't need an
entreprenuer I know that he does a lot
of startup he's extremely successful the
child sex thing like he has like he's
pulling down a lot of pedophile but he's
not known for being deep he's a VC
investor in a lot of stuff exactly
that's all I'm saying like I just
branding like it's like if screech did
something if you plagiarize Martin
Luther King it's like okay well yeah you
picked a good person I have a vision
[Laughter]
it's just great it's funny but yeah so
that's why one of the recent graduates
her name is abby smith she posted on
facebook this video of like the
side-by-side comparison that's great and
yeah wait so he got kicked out he got
suspended without pay everyone and
everyone in school does the least amount
of work possible from the principal from
the students from the teachers everybody
no one's [ __ ] doing a hundred percent
that's what smart people do yeah yeah so
Ashton Kutcher heard about
and he tweeted I never met anyone that
takes schoolwork serious
sorry tweeted imitation is the sincerest
form of flattery that mediocrity can pay
to greatness which is a quote from Oscar
Wilde and then he puts an Asterix cite
your sources kid and Hackl faculty
that's fine awesome that's funny
yeah worried saying Nikki Nikki's always
she's always says ash and anxiety cuz
she took schools will say oh yeah Nikki
dude I never met anyone that does their
homework really I did my homework what
are you talking about how do you get an
mba without doing any homework no I mean
like elementary junior high all of my
homework I had to do all my homework
we were just bad kids that's why do you
have a marriage or do you guys I have a
BA Amy too bad a bad what I go meet ups
right no I hope yes no I have a BA no BS
Sciences [ __ ] what do I have marketing
isn't sciences no have a PA you have ups
what do you have
I want to UCB no I was only a freshman
there through the whole program I'm a
graduate thank you I went to a technical
school oh yeah okay education decertify
for flip I go to UC it's a lot of me yet
we just got a mortar so I'm an official
gonna get our motorcycle license almost
all the last time and I'm gonna get my
scan of your license eventually you have
this block jumps for that yeah and I'm a
samurai see my buddy has that yeah
that's my goal I want to do it it's
gonna happen I'm gonna degrees do you
have yeah I have my central processing
technician certificates I have a GED
that's tight that's my I didn't graduate
junior high though I have my high school
diploma I didn't go to Judy I have my
elementary school diploma at the end of
the date right now bro what about this
interesting content this is what big
if we get like 20,000 views on this
video
I won't wonder why no one's sharing I've
an expired CPR certification I've had
like four of those I want to do that
before I have kids I want to I want to
learn CPR you should it's actually
really helpful
yeah do I purposely don't want to learn
why cuz I want someone else to do it you
know what I hope people I put my lips on
nobody you know do
dude I was not a cruise ship and and we
were all having dinner and then all of a
sudden it was like is there a doctor
here like over them no yeah I heard that
on an airplane yeah I know it was one of
those things right you just you're just
like oh man I can do [ __ ] do you really
want it to well you you you immediately
want to help no matter who you are cuz
you're human being right so I see cuz
you know you just said I jump in I jump
in when when there's things actually
happening but then in my heart I don't
want to do it so I'm like the opposite
like how people are like always bragging
like yeah I can do it and I'm like man I
don't want to [ __ ] do it
and then when there's things that go
down I'm like I gotta do something see
I'm not bragging that I would do it I'm
saying that knowing that I didn't have
the skills to do anything was a weird
feeling yeah I think you'd like medical
[ __ ] like if someone's dying I just
watch them suffer but like if there's
some kind of violence or danger or
something that's about to happen I feel
like what am I gonna do I really think
I'm between like fight or flight or
freeze I think I'm a freeze siap at to
go I'll just be like what's happening
right now like I can't even process this
like what that's how I feel about
emotions oh yeah yeah I wanted to talk
about motions I got to work through it
but before it would be like seeing like
a like a tighter [ __ ] a hippo I'm just
like huh talk to me talk to me and I'm
like you see a tiger [ __ ] on a hippo
why I don't know if I feel about this
how came out so fast though he's a
[ __ ] poet yeah that would be weird if
a tiger plucks a hippo yeah I'd be like
oh I
that dog said you know the dog barked Oh
Maddie came up so fast like it I think
you really saw a tiger [ __ ] a hippo
wouldn't asking me like taking it hard
feeling the same no how are you able to
fix that yeah uh slowly just tell me
what animal is yeah well there's a tiger
that's on top she's like well what's on
the bottom hippopotamus yeah so each
time you just described the tiger foot
is seeing that make you feel and then he
goes what do you think about that I've
used step at a time
and what makes you confused about animal
[ __ ] horse before no I don't think
you do you normally see yeah yeah
usually I see Tigers with tigers and
hippos and hippos if there's someone on
a plane and they're suffocating I'm all
like I'm glad I'm not a doctor cuz if
that [ __ ] dies everyone's gonna
look at me oh I never thought of that
they wouldn't know practice you're
trying and they feel bad for you that
you couldn't save sure that's true
that's true I just put myself in a
donkey shoes because I would look at the
doctor like you suck as a doctor I'm
getting another doctor yeah I'm like
what oh man you probably didn't [ __ ]
pass medical school really good yeah you
barely like really good dude that's like
you you guys told me that you guys
watched your instructor get knocked out
by another guy right you guys went to a
fight oh oh yeah yeah fine and your
instructor got knocked out by another
guy how come you didn't go like hey the
other guy can you be your instructor now
that's the name of the game because I
know what happens in anything there's
always a puncher's chance that's what
they call it
I seen my instructors just way better
than him lucky put in the back of your
head aren't you like other guys kind of
better no I don't really think that I
just think it's funny to feel that you
ever do that where it's like you don't
really mean it but then you play it in
your head cuz it's so funny to think it
all the time like it's funny to think
the inappropriate thing oh yeah of
course
you know I can't want to go back on what
you were saying about like you know if
you if he beat your coach why don't you
go to him that's kind of similar to
what's happened
here how the vice principal I mean the
principal plagiarize this like -
encroachers entire speech it's like then
how like you know you're telling your
kids like the kids that go to your
school you can't plagiarize the thing
you're doing it like you gotta lead by
example dude you telling me the people
there aren't just going there to collect
a paycheck and they're [ __ ] tired of
these kids
not everyone I mean maybe that's why
they get paid very little because
they're trying to get people that are
passionate about it that sounds like an
excuse of someone with a lot of money
that wants to pay someone nothin I feel
like there are those passionate teachers
and you know they [ __ ] care and I
think all of them were there at one
point but after you after a while
they're like [ __ ] these kids welcome all
and in like maybe one or two are still
like there's one or two still there with
hope and then they get crushed yep it's
like a millionaire that doesn't tell his
new girlfriend that he's a millionaire
he tries to hide it because he wants to
know like is she gonna love me for me oh
well the best [ __ ] is this principal guy
being like integrity on a [ __ ] strand
yeah and he just copied the whole thing
lifted all of it [ __ ] amazing
[Music]